welcome to the data science hangout
thanks up for jumping on and co-hosting
with me today
so welcome back to all the familiar
faces and to those joining for the first
time
it's really fun to see this like
recurring group starting to form
but for anyone new today these
discussions cover a variety of different
topics on data science leadership in the
enterprise
but really focus on questions that are
most important to you all
so
again no agenda and everyone is welcome
to join in live or put any questions
that you have in the chat
that said i'd like to just jump in here
and introduce uh sep dad satan executive
director
rwe and i
am
checking with you that is real world
evidence
analytics at concert
yeah
um but steph's passion about learning
and exploring new concepts and ideas and
and bringing them to life i found that
on your website somewhere and i will say
except i did learn a few random things
about you making that sad and true like
djing and foot golf
but would you be able to kick things off
by introducing yourself and sharing a
bit about the work you do
yeah happy to i'm glad to be here i
think i've already been part of several
weeks of discussion and it's highly
valuable so i definitely encourage you
guys to uh share your perspectives i
think this is a great opportunity to
just learn from everyone
um
so uh yeah so my name is septon um
my formal training education is in
actually like molecular physiology so i
studied uh immune cells and t cells
um and then made a did a brief postdoc
at genentech studying b cells
the another immune cell and then that's
when i said i was going to leave
academics uh and join a startup company
uh which was sciapps
where we worked with real world data and
real world evidence there
so that was most of my 10-year seven and
a half years there
a brief stint at kite for a couple years
doing it for their r d group
um and then uh and then recently joined
uh concert ai back in the real world
data space uh about six months ago now
so that's kind of the brief
uh tour there um
with respect to what what i do i'm
at
concert i'm mainly kind of focused on
achieving kind of scalability
reproducibility
doing some training
and trying to at this point really kind
of focusing on architecture um and
trying to kind of uh gather our teams um
and
smooth some edges so to say
awesome thank you sub
um so while we kind of wait for people's
questions to come in and i'd love to
kick it off with with one of our
questions we we often ask people but
what is something that you're really
excited about in data science right now
um
i think broadly speaking i'm just
excited about the level of um
of
adoption businesses are having around
around data in general and how it can
impact their uh their business
so um
i mean i remember probably early 2010s
uh you know data science is this kind of
term that's popping up people are kind
of what is it what is it probably still
today we ask what that is right but um
uh but a lot of businesses really
weren't really sure
what that meant and how it could benefit
them but i think you know now like a
decade later
we're seeing um the a lot of companies
ipo'ing that are in the data space we're
seeing increased adoption of cloud
computing we're seeing a lot of
businesses really shift
shift towards data which really kind of
i think solidifies
that data is here to stay all data
science data analytics and data adjacent
roles are here to stay and that there's
a lot of value to be
provided so that's to me exciting um and
we're still kind of obviously shaking a
lot of those things out to figure out
what that means on a broad level um
yeah and i think you know i think what's
interesting probably on the forefront is
also synthetic data um
i haven't played a whole lot in that
space but that's pretty interesting to
see how
you know yeah we generate a lot of data
uh
you know in general
but not a lot of that data is
necessarily usable or if it is usable
um it may be sensitive in which case we
have different strategies to allow you
know technologies like ai and ml to kind
of proceed
in a uh in a more safe manner so that's
kind of exciting
awesome is
a company being like data first
something that you like first look at
when
deciding where you wanted to work or i
was just talking with someone yesterday
and they were
saying like
when they were deciding which companies
to to take a look at that was a huge
factor for them and and maybe
something for people to consider um
looking for new roles
yeah i mean yes and no i for me i i like
a challenge um so sometimes they want to
be data first um and so that's where
i'll i'll raise my hand so cool let's
let's uh let's figure out what that game
plan is going to be um
but yeah i mean obviously
i think a business and especially the
leadership to have
to have the interest to want to go into
that direction and enable either enable
the company to be that way if they're
not or to just enable the company to
continue to be that way i think are both
you know highly important uh
attributes at least for me and i'm sure
a lot of the other people here on the
call that are so interested in data so
definitely
i'll wait i'm waiting for a few people
to put some questions into the chat or
feel free to jump in live but
yeah um something else i thought might
be helpful to cover is like certain
challenges that you
face or something that you think is
broken in in data science today
um
that's a great question um
there are a couple levels to that so um
i think i'll start at let's say the
lowest level which is the the analysts
data scientists i think that since there
isn't a single path to become a data
scientist people come from all walks of
life
um
you also then get this varied very
very training and it's like a pro and a
con because on one hand
usually they have domain expertise
usually they have you know great skill
set but those
with teams or how they've worked with
teams in the past
that may or said
sorry that was i thought that was my
internet for a second
was i was i breaking up you were
breaking up for a little bit i thought
it was on my end it
is it okay for everyone else now
let me know
yeah okay yep it's good good for me
sorry you might need to repeat just the
no that's okay
clearly my internet doesn't like what
i'm saying so
um
is trying to try to
censor me
um
oh yeah so frank just got a new modem
yeah that's how i would react to uh it's
probably mine i don't know
um so yeah so i think one of the the
interesting aspects or i guess gaps
might be how people come into data
science and the very you know directions
that they come which would
kind of um
you know when we talked about training
and like trying to get everybody on the
same page just a little bit more
difficult than if you were to kind of
kind of let's say have a standard path
to become
a data scientist so to say so i think
that's one of the
challenges currently in the field that's
at that low level that i was kind of
referring to
um at the higher level i think we're in
a bit of a transition period as
businesses are starting to kind of
realize the value that that data might
provide them
not all not all let's say leadership or
a lot of businesses are data savvy and i
think again that goes back to this
training aspect where
you know you need to translate your work
for a business leader
or someone who might not kind of
understand it um you know that still
exists and it's kind of will always
shape how let's say the data science
groups get resources and funding um
and it will also shape you know how
businesses will kind of
uh move forward and plot their course so
those are the two kind of i guess levels
that that i think are gaps in in our
current data realm
yeah
on that point of kind of
communicating it out to the business i
know frank you just had a question
around business impact um would you want
to ask that one live
sure
um
so
everyone has a different answer to this
but
in terms of business impact how do we
show stakeholders or users
the value it brings obviously it's it's
uh
making its way to the top and leaders
are acknowledging it because to your
points up this industry is growing the
jobs are here to stay
uh are there any examples that you have
um on how you you demonstrate that
obviously the more quantitative the
better but oftentimes
uh that is that is a challenge
and so to to i guess to clear that up so
are you in are you referencing like
let's say
enabling a new arm of the business or
just a show that showed the business
that hey look we need more resources
this data is actually very valuable when
have this is how it will
yeah i guess i would go um i'll
i'll skew it to my perspective but
um
when i think about how stakeholders and
leaders view the data science
teams and folks i think they think that
every data scientist can do everything
all of the tools like they can do
everything right so they're like you
have five people
right you should be able to do all of
these projects and
and and maybe even more but the truth is
there's only one person who has
experience in forecasting right and
super challenging to take on the 10
forecasting projects for the one person
and get the other people up to speed
and then at that point they're like well
i mean if you can't do that then you
cost too much
and until you can like offset that with
what is the value you're showing up with
whether it's like cadence of delivery
how fast you can work
and it's really hard i find to relate
that all the way end all the way to the
end of the cycle where you're actually
saving business cost or bringing in uh
increased revenues
yeah i mean uh that's a great question i
think that that generally applies to not
only data science but many other teams
as well um i mean even engineering teams
you sometimes you have one person that's
like
the front end developer right
um
i you know i think that what i found
success with um you know and it's hit or
miss sometimes right it's not not
everything is a single solution or
single path to a solution um what i
found success is just trying to be as
close to the business as possible and
understanding what their needs are
sometimes you find that
they just move too quickly to even know
what their needs are and so you have to
kind of help guide them and in doing
that
you build this kind of partnership where
you then have more value and
understanding of how you can kind of
guide
um you know orient your team to provide
that value um and then they get closer
to understanding it
um
that would be kind of how i've found a
bit of success
um
but yeah it's not always it's super it's
not always straightforward is there
anybody else that also has kind of uh
want to chime in as experience in that
no
i checked to see who unmuted themselves
yeah and i mean um you know
like i'm trying to think of uh think of
examples i mean sometimes it's so
so
my experience has been very it's been
quite varied i've worked uh as like
early employee at startup i've worked at
like large pharma companies like like
you know gilead kite right
and it always varies right at a small
startup
uh you know it's always go go go
priorities are shifting all the time and
so where i ended up trying to provide
value was yeah occasionally you have to
make those deliveries um as as requested
but um when you're building the
infrastructure in a way that makes that
delivery let's say reproducible or makes
that infrastructure reproducible
and then and they see the speed at which
you can turn things around in the future
um because inevitably we all probably
have experienced this someone's going to
ask a question or want a delivery and
then they want some variant of that
delivery three months from now right
and so you go build you build that first
iteration maybe it takes you you know a
week longer to do it
but if you do it right the next time
they come around it turns around in a
day they they fall out of their chairs
right and i think that that's where all
of a sudden
you're you're showing that look this is
this is the value of doing things in a
manner that's that's reproducible and
scalable because we're saving costs
where we are turning things around that
impresses you know the customer
um and uh you know and those are the
things where you're like okay you know
regardless of who's doing it the the
the operation of the data
program is is is efficient right and so
um i take i take pride in that i love
kind of efficiency in that regard and so
kind of scale and all those things are
kind of an interest for me but i don't
know and now i'm just probably
blabbering i'd love to hear other
people's take
how much uh how much time is
spent on
prep work i guess for for doing
what most people would think of like you
know the data science analysis versus um
versus doing uh
that makes sense oh yeah yeah i mean
this is uh
uh i think it varies by industry um in
the industry that i'm in i mean we're
dealing with with uh
people's health data
and it can be very very messy
but at the same time it's very very
important we're trying to recreate a
patient's journey through
treatment and whatnot and we want to
make sure that we get it right and so it
ends up being
quite slow quite methodical there's a
lot of people that are involved to make
sure that we're making clinically
appropriate assumptions um to then
finally get to you know how we get to
our data set right and so it's probably
a lot longer in the real world data
space than than perhaps others but i
don't have a whole lot of experience in
in other
other types of data sets um i think you
know you probably the the adage that's
like 80 of a data scientist's time is
spent cleaning
cleaning data and organizing data
uh might be appropriate i i don't know
i've never really kind of thought about
it to be honest i just kind of like get
it done and try to do it in a manner
that i don't have to do it
like repetitively try to build on
knowledge
is that something that you have to um
with other folks in the business about
or do they usually understand
you know there's a lot that goes into
you know the pre-cooking
yeah i mean i think that goes to
uh i guess to go back to rachel's
question about what gets me excited
right so what gets me excited is that
great all these businesses are very
interested in data we're here to stay
right
but there's a flip side to that is that
data literacy
uh also is required um and so
um
there are various levels so some people
are are happy to understand the the
nuance and the nitty gritty of why
it takes so long to kind of stitch these
things together
and then there are others that are
saying look we need to deliver to the
customer this is what we want
and i and i get that it takes time but
hurry up right
um
and so yeah i mean i always try to kind
of simplify and you know really kind of
point out uh give status updates i mean
transparency for me is is really
important so if you're transparent with
your stakeholders and you know they
recognize what you know what what the
blockages are and i think everybody that
you're going to get engaged with is
going to want to know so that they might
be able to help out i think that again
helps with establishing that
relationship and and having them get a
little bit closer to the data and
understand some of the
um you know the hurdles that you might
face
um
but uh but yeah sometimes um you know
patience is is perhaps thin and they
don't quite
quite get it um and but that comes with
this other side if you're going to be
more data company we're going to have to
have more data literacy and
what what are our better methods of
perhaps working with data and
how it can
how it can enhance us rather than let's
say throw people at a problem
you know do it intelligently from an
engineering standpoint
so that you can scale your operations so
you can throw more people at it but when
you're throwing people at it you're
providing more company value rather than
trying to
uh you know
wade through the mud with increasingly
large data sets or increasingly complex
data sets
okay
good jump in
sep you mentioned i think you used two
words partnership and relationship
somewhere as you were describing that
and
i um i have found every single time i've
had a new team that partnership and
relationship with my stakeholders in the
business universe users is immense right
once they they trust you and they say oh
you you're actually on my team like
we're working towards the same goal and
they get it and
one of the tried and true ways i've done
that is
if it's transportation i read a
transportation textbook and we're not in
the office anymore but like once my
partners see that i have a
transportation textbook on my desk
they're like oh you really are like on
this and trying to solve this problem
right you're not just the data person or
david team over there that's huge
with that said i've had success there
but
scaling relationships and partnerships
is really hard because they both take
time
right and we
we want to be data teams and we want
things we want to do things efficiently
and scale it across
hundreds of thousands of decisions
um
i don't know does anyone have any
thoughts on how to balance scale and
efficiency with relationships and
partnerships
yeah i'd love to hear from others too
that's a great point hi
hi everyone
nice sergio hi i'm here hi i'm sergio
and i'm actually connected from bolivia
and it's so interesting to be
here and listening all the old
experiences you're talking about and
actually well i started a company a well
data science company here in bolivia
about maybe
six months ago or something like that
well previously we me and my partner we
have been working on different different
consulting projects related to data
science well managing data but it's so
interesting right now that well i want
to show you what my experience is at
this point we well we believe we are
doing really well because we're starting
to get involved in interesting projects
with different
er
with different sectors for example
mining sector financial sector and in in
well what we have we have noticing will
our approach is to
or our strategy is to to have a first
meeting for example with these different
companies and we are not offering
exactly like solutions or services or
products like our first approach is to
try to make them understand
what
all this idea is about and well
something that is super important i
believe that that they have to
understand is that well data science is
kind of a
uh structure that is this is uh
is a well
it has three main parts that is
basically the the well the programming
part the i.t part then the statistical
in an analytical part and then the well
one of the most important is the the the
the know-how and how how everything
works actually what frank was talking
about like talking about transportation
for example you have to being as being a
a uh a partner or working for them you
have to start understanding what the
work is about and understand being part
of the company so
i think that's super important like when
you when you try to to have a
a
well a relation with any company or any
any industry whereas you also have to
understand uh what it is about and how
it works how everything everything works
and work really really close to them to
to be able to to develop these solutions
and and well that's
the experience we are living right now
it seems like the
like when you talked about
infrastructure like i think sometimes
you think servers but you were talking
about like how you actually set up those
projects so that you can make things
reproducible but it seems like those
relationships are almost a part of the
infrastructure as well
and it's curious just talking a bit more
about
how how you do make that infrastructure
reproducible
yeah great question um
so
yes
i mean reproducibility and scalability
all i mean it relies on the success of
training making sure everybody's doing
things and the processes are all the
same and it also is related to this
partnership and relationship so
um i think it's interesting for myself
that i spent a couple years in it
uh at kite pharma which is a common
thing that you know a lot of people on
the other side of the analytics like
need to deal with at larger companies
and so it was really nice to kind of get
the perspective from the i.t side and
and now come to concert and say okay i
get how it works like i can you know
um
so yeah so part of part of
reproducibility for me is
you know uh
everything i mean it's like
it really involves everything so you
know making sure everyone's kind of
using um yeah you know let's say version
control the same way
uh that naming conventions are the same
um we built a
basically a a package
an r package so that when people create
new uh because we use our studio so we
create a new package so when you create
a new our studio project that project
will always be the same so it creates
the same folders
the same setup so when i'm talking
infrastructure to make it reproduce
along everything from how you use code
how you name your code how you name your
variables
how your projects are set up how your
files are named all of that stuff it
they're they're really really annoying
little little things but they bubble up
to be so much more because when you
create a
project for example an analytical
project
everybody then it becomes a transposable
unit that means i can take my project i
go on vacation for a year someone
emergency request someone else can pick
it up and know exactly where the data is
know exactly where the scripts are you
know etc and they could they should be
able to pick it up with a lot less
uh you know overhead for having to
figure out oh well how did sep organize
this stuff like i don't know right that
that takes sometimes days
um
so that's that's one
uh i think a big part of it actually to
be honest is a lot setting up a lot of
that real basic stuff and then it also
makes it much smoother so that every
time you set up a project you don't have
to like think about
think about those things you just kind
of go
this is where you write your stuff and
whatever
and then we happen to use our connect
as well i know that there are other
solutions but that allows us a feedback
loop i think
one of the aspects that um
you know that we end up talking a lot
about in these these weeks are like
communication
um and how you communicate with business
stakeholders and so
you know if we're going to set up that
you know our studio project we want to
then be able to publish it whatever that
output is whether it's an api whether
it's a product
a report whatever an application we want
to be able to publish it and publish it
in a central location so people aren't
trying to search for it everywhere
and then we have a url we could share
that url and we get this feedback loop
it's not sitting in somebody's email and
part of a chain you have to then go
through your email and so we've kind of
streamlined it
and that allows us to kind of you know
basically hit a conveyor belt if there's
iterations changes we can kind of do
that and then it's modular so other
people can kind of pick it up so that's
the kind of
i guess reproducibility and scalability
that i'm referring to
thank you and i i see trevor has a
question which kind of touches upon this
as well around quality of data trevor
would you want to introduce yourself and
ask that question
hi everyone yeah
nice meeting you all
very good sessions every week
yeah so my name is trevor thompson
actually from jamaica
um work for a global gaming company
um i'm very interested in the
infrastructure
when we talk about data we speak about
models we speak about data science but
um the emphasis on talking about
the quality of data that we use
garbage in garbage out
right
and the process of collecting cleaning
and storing i know it's maybe it may be
it is a data engineering process but of
course it's very important when you talk
about data science even since week
i was involved in a process with an
application
that collects the coordinates
of some locations
and
we found out recently that the
the collection process is not precise
enough so we're ending up in a situation
where where we have this consultant
who wants a great degree of precision in
terms of identifying a location
but the radius
of the collection points is like
83 meters so that's definitely not as
precise as i would want it to be
so
some of these things you don't even
realize until you're really digging deep
right so
this has always been on my mind when we
talk about the quality of data that we
use all throughout the data science
process
you know so it's just about thinking
about that
um
you know so that's what's on my mind
here
yeah um thanks for chiming in trevor uh
by the way i love your accent jamaican
accents one of my favorites um
uh so feel free to chime in further um
[Music]
uh
if anybody else has has something to say
about it i know from uh from
there's many way architecture and
infrastructure can refer to a variety of
things
um and there's many ways to kind of
solve for whatever your business
purposes are um i mean generally you
have to partner pretty closely with your
data engineering team it kind of depends
sometimes data engineers themselves have
a little bit of an analytical bent to
them so they're always kind of
constantly checking
other times there's a dedicated qc team
that's constantly evaluating and kind of
sampling um as data moves from from
place to place just to make sure that
you are collecting the right information
and that uh all the transformations are
going accordingly
other times and again depends on the
size of the company and how roles are
broken up you know the data science team
should have someone that is actually
kind of evaluating or at least
generating some sort of
report out of wherever the staging areas
of your existing data is uh is sitting
um to kind of hopefully prevent that
where you do all this work and
eventually you get it you're like oh boy
this is not what we wanted at all
um
so
many ways to kind of solve that i i
don't know what your particular setup is
but that's those are a couple ways in
which um you know we've solved that in
the past which is just to kind of
uh somehow what through whatever team
get our hands on things a little bit
early and sample
just to make sure things are kind of
as we expect them to be
anybody else have thoughts on that
cool try to wait for like
seven seconds for people to chime in
there
but yeah if anyone else has uh thoughts
about that i think
mike thomas you chimed in a little bit
about that and
more so amount about the time spent on
design do you want to add anything there
yeah i don't know i think you know sep
spoke pretty well to it i just find
that
communicating up front and i think
design kind of does this intrinsically
um is when you spend a lot of time on
designing kind of what the output
solution is going to be it requires you
to bring all the stakeholders to the
table up front
um you know the owners of the data the
owners of the the platform the people
who are going to be using your solution
you know on the ground a day in and day
out
the technical folks in your analytics
team and then also the it
team that that might be enabling
the solution to even work security
infrastructure stuff like that um i
think when you focus
when at least you attack the project
with a design mindset up front and
really focus on nailing down um you know
what the end-to-end process is going to
look like
i think it pays off
quite a bit in the end in ensuring that
you know whatever you put together uh is
is well architected
um you know maybe you're ensuring that
there's a data dictionary behind all the
data that's that's being used
um you know things like that and that
the output is is what everybody's
expecting it to be i find myself
nowadays probably drawing as many
spending as much time drawing
architecture diagrams as i am writing
our code
which um
you know is fun if you're into that but
i think it's an important um
step to take in any project and i think
it's a good team mindset to have as well
i like uh daniel's question from earlier
that kind of relates this as well mike
but
like balancing
that form like that making the process
and making it more formal versus getting
the results quickly for someone
um daniel would you want to kind of
chime in and give
your background and how you've
experienced that
sure sure absolutely um so my name is
daniel i'm a lead data scientist with
nestle
uh and it's
touching a little bit on what what stuff
you were speaking to before in that kind
of like
if time was not a requirement then i
think
i personally know a lot of people in in
our positions would kind of want things
to be as formal and as repeatable as
possible so that
to your point like somebody else can
come in if i'm away or i can easily
understand and read somebody else's code
but the drawback is that it takes time
to do
uh and so one of the things that that i
struggle with personally on the team
is
i probably lean much more towards the
formal side and not everybody does
and i have struggled figuring out how
much to kind of push those others
to kind of fit my system so to speak
at the same time knowing that uh
they're they're
highly competent data scientists in
their own right they just
structure things a little bit
differently than i do
and if i
kind of not force them but kind of uh
try to influence them to fit into one
standard way of doing things that slows
them down and the the
end result of whatever it is that
they're building or analyzing uh is
isn't as available as soon as possible
so so it's just that
constant struggle at nestle now but as
well as other places where i've been
like how how much do you try to make
things repeatable and formal versus
uh kind of like every person is their
own system
yeah um that's that's a that's a great
question and it's a it is a comment
situation uh for better for worse
um i think again it depends on on the
culture of the team and and what the
what the business is really kind of
after i think um and it depends on i
don't know what relationships are like i
i i like to try and lead by example um
so at the very least if i'm finding that
it's difficult to kind of
you know hey like look this is a this is
a large team or or the team's really
everyone's kind of just doing their
thing and in their own uh in their own
lanes at the very least i try to
simplify it for myself
and try to make my work
more reproducible and in many cases what
ends up happening is whether there's a
you know code review or whether there is
uh you know future fire drills or
whatever
um that will that process will always
win out right and when someone else sees
it they're like oh maybe that that's
cool maybe i want to try that how did
you do that right
um and so yeah sometimes it's not so
easy just to kind of you know go dictate
to people and say look like this is how
you should do it
um
until they kind of come to the
realization themselves um
and so that was
you know that's one one method that
might work where it's just at the very
least you could do it for yourself it
does take time
but even small wins are important right
so i've been in situations where
especially in a startup where it's like
okay we need something in two weeks that
we don't have anything like nothing
exists right now but we need to fill it
for two weeks right so it just ends up
being okay just dive onto the keyboard
but but even in those cases wherever i
can
uh have kind of an engineering mindset
and modularize what i can
uh i know that those pieces can be used
either on other projects or this project
becomes much easier
with future revisions um
and
and that i think that goes back to what
i'm what i was saying is everybody comes
from so many different angles
um into data science sometimes that
engineering piece uh isn't there and so
you know you know showing people that
that you could do it a particular way
might be helpful
i might have a couple things to add
there as well that's okay
yeah
i think probably
i think this is what steph was speaking
to but maybe this is a more high-level
view
of the answer to your question i think
it's
a belief that collaboration
in the end will make your team more
successful and make your projects more
successful and more efficient right
you're not going to get
collaboration collaboration's not going
to go as well if everybody's in their
lane and they have different standards
and you don't have necessarily code
review because somebody's writing their
code in one style and other people are
writing their code in a totally
different style so i think the way maybe
to go about fostering that or preaching
it would be
um to get people to buy into the idea
that collaboration is going to make your
team more efficient effective
get you
in the end at the end of the day once
you have things set up
you know get you those results quicker
and i think seth made a great point
about small wins i think small wins in
this case in terms of you know just even
styling functions or documentation
around your code and things like that um
can go a long way towards turning on the
light bulb in people's mind about how
some standards around how folks are
writing their code can can be affected
yeah so just to add
a bit there
so
[Music]
one of the selling points for us when we
talk about data science and about using
tools like r
is about efficiency right
the ability to produce
um reproducible code or results
and efficiency so
even though we may think documentation
and structure is boring and it is
we know
if it's not in place what the results
are
right
so essentially something that would take
you two minutes
may take you an hour
right and in terms of even communication
communication with members on your team
or even outside
when there is no commonality you're
talking about in jamaica or you call it
chinese telephone where you're trying to
get to someone you can't get to them
because the language is different
so you know what is so interesting about
this conversation now is that we're
talking about infrastructure we're
talking about communication and none of
this is really about
data analysis itself but how important
all the the the tenets are all
connecting points around the data
analysis itself is extremely important
that's what i get from that
definitely
yeah trevor i want to save that snippet
that you just said there because i i
think that is so so important
and
and also like they
thinking about the communication back to
the team about that as well and like how
do you communicate that back to the
business if
oh they got this one report in one day
because you had already set that process
up how do you help them understand like
every report doesn't just come in in one
day like that
yeah uh yeah i mean it's it's uh it's
again it's like showing the art if
possible um yeah and i think when when
they realize
you know we do you do things
in a smart way then you can gain speed
um they're more than happy to then
support that right so um if if a new
request comes that's outside of the
scope of the original request they they
then have an understanding of what it
took to make that original one and then
they'll want it again because
it's again it's like building knowledge
and it's a building scale right not ever
you're not going to get everything in
one one go but if you do things you know
uh
majority the right way the first time uh
over time you're gonna have a bolus of
knowledge that you're
you're enabling the the remainder of the
the business um whether that's other
groups whether that's marketing whatever
to be able to do what they do and i
think that that's where the the value uh
comes out right it's not just um
you know sitting at a keyboard and
you know
writing out the script and getting a
result you could do that and that works
but you're trying to think a bit more
long term
so yeah that's at least how we've moved
we've approached it
are there a few um small organizational
or or collaboration activities that
are sort of your go-to's uh
you know when leaning a team or uh
you know group of people into a more
more formal way of doing things
um
i can't share that information that's
proprietary okay um
[Laughter]
i've got a secret no um
no i think i you know
i don't know i i
i think there's uh you know one of the
questions that i think that was
discussed perhaps in the past was like
people that are interested into getting
into leadership right
um there's naturally going to be a
transition point where your hands aren't
on the keyboard as often
um you know where you're not you're not
doing the analysis per se but now you
have to manage a team
uh and and and grow that team and and
com and with that come different
responsibilities and so
some of those responsibilities are
just evangelizing your team and being
able to communicate and work with other
business partners and so i think
you know um i've been now in
i think two situations where i have
either started a team from scratch or
the team is basically pretty new
and i think the most important thing is
obviously you get your bearings first
but um then basically going on a uh on a
tour right speaking to all the business
partners uh different stakeholders
around the company and trying to
understand what it is they do how they
engage with data how they envision
working with
that team
um and and just maintaining those
relationships like constantly having
having conversations and not being
afraid to like help out when you can
right sometimes some of these groups
might be uh resource strapped
and so jumping in and trying to solve
little problems here and there
may be helpful and i think that builds
the rapport it kind of accelerates a
little bit about this partnership
building and um you know really allows
uh allows you as a group to have a
better understanding of the business so
that you can align uh your your
priorities in accordance with that and
and the goals of the business
but also allows them to understand how
you operate um and what benefit you can
bring to the table um and then when
those things kind of align then you
start to be a little bit more closely
integrated
does that answer the question
and the the one follow-up i have is on
that tour is there a like a balance
between
fielding
requests or projects and then like
seeking out areas where
you want to bring something to the table
yes and i think this depends again on on
how the business is led um so if the
business has very clear
goals uh and guidance um then your group
should always really kind of be aligned
with that other business units may may
or may not have
uh you know
alignment in that regard and so
you can't just you i mean some people
are nice and they just want to field
whatever request okay fine you could do
that you're still gonna you know get
some wins but it'll be also a bit more
distracting towards you achieving what
you need to do as a team to become most
efficient because now you have perhaps
extraneous projects
whereas if the business is uh you know
some some businesses might not be so
clear on their on their objectives and
goals maybe it's new maybe it's fluid
um and so that requires partnership with
those other business units are we really
you know doing the best biggest bang for
our buck and doing these projects and so
yeah there's a balancing act you don't
want to field all requests it doesn't
hurt to have an understanding of all the
requests so that you have uh an idea and
they can maybe say hey you know what
like there's a piece of this that we
might be able to work on or a piece of
this or maybe we can just tackle this
for you
um
uh and then and don't be afraid to kind
of also ask right ask how other people
might be able to help
um sometimes that's just you know being
involved in maybe
you know weekly or bi-weekly or
bi-monthly or whatever presentations
that they have so that you're aware of
their work and i think that
that shows that you have an invested
interest in uh in them their success
um and hopefully they reciprocate as
well and i think that then brings the
whole business together and it also
really helps the the data science and
data analytics group as well
awesome i'm i'm trying to like group
together some of the questions so that
we don't keep like jumping back back and
forth but i think on this topic
i saw tracy you commented on
a helpful resource for cultivating
collaboration in data science would you
want to maybe introduce yourself and
provide any
additional context on that
sure hi um
i'm tracy thiel and i'm the relatively
new open source program manager at
rstudio um
and so i'm focused on the open source
tools that our studio is building like
the tidy verse and the the elmo verse
and shiny what's tidy verse um so tidy
verses i'm kidding
you know there's all kinds of different
stakeholders i'm first on this call
i was on a tidy models meeting so i'm
sorry it was a little late to this one
um
but yeah i'm just you know wanted to get
a chance to hear you know how people are
are using tools and what challenges
they're facing and i think
um
one of the themes i've seen throughout
my career i've worked in non-profit and
academic spaces as well
is where the challenges are
more social than tools um
which has been you know a lot of this
conversation and so i was part of a
collaboration where we put together this
sort of
there's this framework and um plos uh of
ten simple rules there none of which are
actually simple but that's the title of
the series um so we put together kind of
this this set of things to think about
in these collaborations because
um like what you were saying trevor of
the situation of like getting into a
project and expectations aren't the same
and how do you talk to each other
there's always themes that come up in
any project and it feels like
like oh my gosh i'm the only one that's
doing this wrong but it actually is like
one of the biggest challenges so i've
loved this conversation
that might have some guidelines there i
think one of the other things we focused
on in that um and paper and we think
about in our work in an open source as a
whole is really about
the inclusivity of the environment and
for really a successful collaboration so
setting up
that kind of framework in advance really
allowing everybody to participate
um especially when you have these
challenges of language that's not shared
like your data scientists
maybe use words that your domain
researchers or your domain experts don't
so
a lot to learn
on each side of the fence
definitely thank you tracy
and tracy i see you shared that link a
little bit above in the chat if anyone
wants to to check that out
um but i see you earlier toyin you had a
question which actually tracy might be
able to help provide some context on as
well but
um around tips for
uh transitioning
from academia to industry to and you
want to introduce yourself and expand on
that
certainly um hello my name is toyan ola
i am a behavioral health
data analytics program coordinator
for a state behavioral health agency
and right now i am focused on
trying to get a data workflow together
for
what is essentially a police criminal
justice
and behavioral health program
to divert individuals from the criminal
justice system when they're experiencing
behavioral health emergencies
and we've learned that really a big
component of that will be getting data
9-1-1 call data from public safety
answering points
so to frank's point i've spent a lot of
time learning about the emergency
communications world
so that i do
have some sort of shared language with
them since i was completely naive to
that world beforehand
but i guess you know my question is tips
for transitioning industries when you're
new to an industry don't understand the
language and even on a more technical
side
you know there are some analyses that
are more common in certain industries
than others
so any feedback along those lines would
be helpful
um yeah that's that's a great question i
think for
data scientists so true because the data
science skills are applicable in so many
different contexts but then you have to
get up to speed on that context
um
i guess maybe yeah speak from my
personal experience i mean one is just
like that confidence and that you can
learn it
and like just you know
there's always going to be that that
learning
um
and it sounds like you already have that
and like encouraging that in others just
that sense that like no you're not going
to know everything but what i have
confidence in is is my ability to learn
less
in terms of yeah particular tips um is
one situation i've seen because i also
worked in high performance computing
is maybe that the
the computational person comes in
sort of feeling like they have the
answers
and not
necessarily listening or asking the
right questions um so coming into it
you know
you sound like you're already doing all
of this so you know just like
with that perspective of listening but
also
um
thinking of the right questions to ask
so spending some time not only
like listening but then formulating
questions uh for people to answer and
sometimes
people are better about answering them
like in a conversation and some people
like to have time with the questions and
write them so sometimes i'll provide
different mechanisms for people to give
me information or feedback because
people work in in different ways
so i found that
that to be helpful
i'm in this similar situation now i'm
six weeks into our studio i think so i
i'm trying to learn and ask questions
and um
and then i think yeah that other
strength that it sounds like you're
already bringing to the table is that
synthesis so writing down for yourself
to synthesize the information or write
it down and share it back and say you
know is this is this right
i don't know if those are actually
helpful
it is thank you i appreciate it
thanks tracy steph do you have anything
else to add to that too
um
i'm uh
i i mean i have a lot of interest so i
like between a lot of different kind of
areas i think for me
um and i've i've also hired people that
are from outside of uh outside of
healthcare and outside of pharma
um
exactly what what tracy was saying i
think i think
being being humble
um but also tenacious
where
you know if it's an area that you want
to kind of go explore and apply you know
again your data science skills are are
kind of applicable to anything it's that
domain knowledge that generally people
need to show in a particular interview
um and so yeah if you're tenacious
enough to
be like yeah i could do it and you have
that confidence to do it but also
recognize that you don't know everything
and there may be nuances and be
receptive to listening and getting that
feedback i think those are attributes
that are fantastic um to have because i
love taking people that are outside of
that area just to bring a new
perspective into it but they have to
also have the right personality to be
able to do so in a manner that's not
like
oh like this just you know dismiss or
disregard you know whatever anybody else
is saying because they know it all
um
to that end like even doing you know
small projects uh with data in that
given space that you're interested in
also goes a long way to show that oh
yeah this person's actually pretty
serious about
uh you know pursuing this um you know
they did this in-depth analysis and
whatever sports analytics or something
like that
and so pairing those two together
i think i think you should be totally
fine whichever way you want to go
thank you i appreciate it
if anybody else no one else has anything
to add there i see frank you asked a
question
kind of a follow-up question from a
point made earlier um
around data science being is it
different than data science
infrastructure
uh frank would you want to expand a bit
on that
yeah
um
okay so
as this whole conversation's been going
on i've been thinking about um
and it started when trevor had mentioned
the garbage in garbage out and talking
about his experience there but
uh in the supply chain world i go and
visit distribution centers and write
being in retail so i work for target so
being in retail we have a ton of
distribution centers around the country
and i've been in supply chain for quite
a few years now and when you go into a
distribution center as you're touring
the warehouse and walking around
if you are paid hourly to keep it
organized and pick up the trash that's
what you do if you are a manager walking
the warehouse and you see a piece of
trash on the floor you pick it up if you
are the ceo of the company and you see a
piece of trash in the floor you pick it
up everybody that walks through there is
responsible for
making sure it's organized and clean
because it's safe and the truth is if
our distribution centers don't operate
we don't have product on the shelves we
don't make money and we don't profit
right that's bad for everyone so
everyone feels a responsibility to do
that no matter what your level i think
about the data industry and data driven
companies
and
um
sep you had talked about a data
engineering group versus a data science
group and once people start to have this
perspective where they say hey this is
my job this is what i do
and
they they allow
garbage data to flow through their
pipelines because they were responsible
for the pipeline not what's flowing
through it
i feel like that's a really bad
environment and mindset i see that
responsibility for having the right
infrastructure infrastructure being like
the data because that's the information
everyone that touches it somewhere along
line should to feel that sense of
commitment
to to make it better
um
and i i guess then my head would that's
kind of where i left off and thought
like man the data science part you can't
just be responsible for data munching
and building algorithms
um and then on the other side like the
infrastructure teams the teams that are
building tools
can't just be responsible for the tools
and say like hey tool go out into the
world like good luck out there
it's got to be a team effort i know that
as your company gets bigger and like i
work at target like it gets harder and
harder and harder to instill
responsibility for that
because there's a trade-off right we
only have every individual and team only
has so much time and so much bandwidth
and resources
but it is
absolutely critical if you think you are
going to become a data driven company
tangent over
does anyone have thoughts
standing ovation frank standing ovation
um i i that resonates with me 100 um
i i totally agree like if you're gonna
do work do quality work um and just and
but uh but i i don't know at least for
me the the reality is that uh many of
the people
that i've engaged with uh are on both
sides of the coin some people like it's
just a job i'm gonna do what i'm do what
i'm told and that and it's sometimes and
especially with data it's like it takes
that little bit extra to be like am i
just let me just double check am i
really getting what i'm supposed to be
getting
and then and if you don't do that then
it's again it's on the next target
employee or whatever to go pick up that
trash right
um i so i i don't have a particular
solution i know in our industry
you know patients lives effectively are
on the other end of it um and so that's
that's that's a big motivation for many
people that's why they do what they do
it's not easy um but yeah it's also not
it's
a lot of it also is domain knowledge
like if you're not a clinician
and you don't know what hematocrit is
right like how do i even know what i'm
looking at right so that that that's the
problem we end up having is we have to
have dedicated like informaticists that
are also looking at the data and you
can't rely on a data engineer that might
not even know what the medical
medical information is right but uh but
i totally agree i wish people kind of
did that i think uh hugh has a has
raised his hand
hey uh so no i was just gonna
offer a quick um
aside uh there was a really neat uh
presentation i think colin gillespie
gave last week on practical advice for
arm production that talked a little bit
about uh
infrastructure versus the data science
piece and you know it's all of our
responsibility you know to make sure
things work but at some point i really
like what he said at some point
uh role specialization is is crucial
because you wouldn't ask
it to build your model for you now you
wouldn't ask them to you know do your
exploratory data analysis all that stuff
but you also wouldn't ask the data
scientist to make sure you have a update
schedule or that you know you're all
using the same version of our that kind
of thing so
it's it's neat you talk about how do you
find that balance and
depending on the maturity of your
program and the you know the amount of
support you have you have to find it uh
at your level so
yeah
great
thanks here i just put that link in the
chat as well
i just found the recording there
um i know we're
just at the top of the hour here so if
anyone has to
jump no worries you have to run to
another meeting i do see there's one
other question left that we didn't get
to yet um so i'd love to
chat more about that if sergio is still
on
would you want to introduce yourself are
you already introduced yourself but ask
that question live
yeah sure no it's something i'm leaving
right now because all the companies i'm
working with right there
they don't have anything they're
starting from scratch and it's super
interesting is
it's basically a progressive transition
into the data science culture but
eventually i know and our objective is
is to be able to implement like our
studio connect tools something like that
but maybe hearing about some experiences
maybe you can share about small
companies that just started with with
these data science tools and when is a
good
point to start thinking about or start
implementing other tools that is going
to be part of developing developing
teams data science teams for example
um
i i and anybody else i mean i have a i
have a very specific experience with
this i don't know if anybody else would
like to jump in um
but uh
so
i have a
belief that like
you know you have to have your data kind
of in order before you get your data
scientists and analysts um
a lot of times it ends up being reversed
and then you have a data scientist who
may have like pretty reasonable
experience with like engineering and
getting the data in shape
but um
uh uh but you know that's not
necessarily their area of expertise and
so um eventually as long as that's
understood that that's gonna be
technical debt and it could be redressed
later okay then that may be fine but
generally you're gonna wanna get your
data in order and have a very clear
strategy of how you're ingesting that
data how it's going through its various
stages until it gets to its you know
resting state to to have then products
or whatever build be built on top of it
so i would say that would be that should
probably come first um
and in many cases uh it would be if
possible it would be great that it's
done with someone that has analytics
data science expertise as well because
sometimes the data engineer doesn't have
that other side of the
of the coin and so the two together
would be the greatest kind of start
where you have a data engineer and you
have a data scientist analyst
and then however they prefer to choose i
mean i'm i'm a little bit uh r biased
but you could you could also do this in
python and then you kind of build your
tool set and architecture around that
right so once you have
your pipeline you can then say okay well
how are we going to do the analysis how
are we going to make this scalable how
do we deliver our products and you now
have kind of at least some kind of
foundation for a small team literally
two people
um
very talented people but two people at
least um so
uh that would be that's how
i would if i was to do it uh over i
would do it that way um
i've done it probably in two different
iterations of that too but
thanks up does anyone else have anything
to add to that
mike i feel like your analogies in the
chat also apply to this piece as well
yeah thanks i i was actually thinking a
bit
jumping to a different analogy about
cooking
right you know everyone can cook at home
with the equipment they have to hand you
don't need the very best
but
you know if you want michelin star
cooking
then you've got to have the right people
with the right tools the right skills to
bring it all together
um
and i i think it's easy
just what set was saying it it's not
easy but it's easier
when there's a very small group
because you can have that one-to-one
dialogue that says okay i know what
you're doing you know what i'm doing we
know the tools that we have
let's come together and get this done
when you go to a really big organization
and this comes back to something that
frank was saying
there's a tendency for people to grab
the tools they know
hack it whatever they need to do to get
today's work done and get it out the
door
and the problem there is that in doing
that process they leave a damn mess
everywhere you know they leave the pots
and pans lying about and everything's
you know
messy and they don't clean up afterwards
and so it you know having as the
organization grows
having
people that know what they're doing
you know know exactly what's expected to
get the
what they need to do
do what they need to do and then leave
the place in a tidy framework
because they know that they're going to
have to do it again you know in a minute
or in an hour or tomorrow
um
and so that there's that kind of chevy
thing of mison blast you chop up you get
all the pieces nice and tidy so that
when the orders start coming in thick
and fast you know you can get your job
done
and and my
you know i work in a big organization
and
um you know there's an awful lot of
people who are doing their own way you
know and i kind of like the tidy verse
thing of it's opinionated but it's
opinionated for a reason because you can
then
you know
reproduce that pipeline again and again
and again using the same kind of tools
you know i have lots of colleagues that
learned art 10 years ago and they're all
base r and they're like yeah but i can
do that and base ours like that's great
i'm really happy for you that you can do
that and be sorry this isn't a
competition this isn't code golf you
know i i i'd like us to be able to do it
in a way that i can pass my stuff to you
you can pass your stuff to me
and you know we know what we're gonna
get and we can then be part of that you
know chain of getting stuff out the door
but getting it out the door looking good
smart fulfilling the brief
you know what everyone wants to see on
their plate
i'm sorry i'm all about analogies
i love that
you're inspiring me to go get better
organized
i don't think i see any other
questions in the chat but if i've missed
any please feel free to speak up too
yeah i have to uh drop unfortunately but
i appreciate you guys giving me the time
to
share a little bit of my perspective i
appreciate everybody else who uh also
shared their perspective ask great
questions thank you to uh rachel and our
studio team to putting this together i
look forward to the future ones as well
awesome and sep quick question what's
the best way for people to get in touch
with you if they have other follow-up
questions
uh
google me i guess
yeah yeah uh linkedin is perfectly fine
um but i'm pretty much available on like
whatever platform um but yeah linked is
probably easiest
okay awesome well thank you so much sepp
for for joining and
sharing your insights and you have to
run um
but thank you all for joining as well
and same place same time next week too
if you happen to be free
we'll also put the recordings up
on youtube too
but thank you all have a great rest of
the day
you